nene leakes celebrates her late husband
greg leaks with the help of her former
real housewives of atlanta co-stars and
friends
the celebration of life was held at
nene's lanithia lounge in atlanta
georgia on monday where several of her
former bravo castmates came together to
pay their respects and celebrate greg's
life among those in attendance lisa wu
phaedra parks marlo hampton portia
williams and eva marcel
the event also included some musical
performances from kiki wyatt and famed
gospel performers yolanda adams kim
burrell and leandria johnson
[Music]
ahead of monday's gathering the 53 year
old reality star shared this throwback
snap on instagram alongside the caption
quote today we celebrate you greg with
love just the way you wanted it greg and
nini's son brent shared this clip from
the event to his insta story featuring a
large smiling portrait of his dad along
with the caption love you pop you have
been my light i couldn't do this without
you i couldn't i wouldn't even try
so i want to thank you baby
greg died on september 1st after
battling colon cancer at the age of 66.
meaney first revealed greg had been
diagnosed with stage 3 colon cancer in
june 2018 but as of may 2019 he was
cancer-free question i have is
the type of cancer that greg has
the stage that he's at
is it common that is beatable i would
use chemotherapy at this point to try to
reduce that risk of the cancer coming
back
in june nene revealed his cancer had
returned and two months later she shared
this update on greg's
[Music]
other health greg's fight against cancer
played out on the real housewives of
atlanta during nene's time on the show
but
you never know what's in you until
you're at that door
never thought i had it in me to fight
cancer
and in 2019 nene opened up to et about
sharing that journey on tv i had a lot
of fans to reach out to me caretakers
were emailing me left and right saying
we understand what you are going through
now there were people who did not
understand what a caretaker role is or
they just didn't understand me saying i
was frustrated they were like why are
you frustrated you're not the one with
half that but you know i i was
frustrated because i was a caretaker and
being a caretaker is hard nene and greg
first married in 1997. they remained
together until divorcing in 2011.
however the couple reunited and
remarried in 2013.
will you love her yes comfort her i will
honor her i will and keep her forever
you